Do you want to export your product to the EU,
but aren't certain what rules to follow?
Then the EU Trade Helpdesk is the perfect tool for you!
Here you'll find all you need to know about
the rules and regulations
and any customs duties you'll need to pay.
Let`s say you want to export cocoa butter
from Ghana to France.
First, select your product's country of origin.
Then choose your destination country.
Next, you'll need to find the EU product
code for cocoa butter.
Simply click on “Find my product code”
and then type
"cocoa butter" in the “search” box.
Once you've got your product code,
click on "search“
Now you'll see all the information about exporting cocoa butter
to the EU,
separated into tabs:
First there is "import procedures".
This explains the customs procedures you'll need to follow;
for example the paperwork you'll need to fill out.
Second: "product requirements".
Here you'll find the health, safety and
technical standards
and the labelling rules for your product.
Then, there is "import duties".
This will show you the duty you'll have to pay at customs
including any discount you might be eligible for.
We also show you any other taxes that apply in the
EU country you're exporting to
as these affect the final price of your product.
The "rules of origin" help us define the
"economic nationality" of your product
which is important when you claim a duty discount.
And lastly,
you'll also find how much of your product the EU imports already
and from where
information you may need for your business plan.
So, with the EU Trade Helpdesk and your
great product,
you'll have all you need to
crack the world's biggest market!